not everyone needs a podcast but the
reason I'm making this video is everyone
needs to try to have a podcast of course
not everyone's going to be good at it as
a matter of fact most people will not be
good at it however the point of this
video is so many of you have been
contemplating it so many of you have
been debating it but you're scared
you're scared of nobody's gonna listen
you're scared that you're not going to
be good at it good news that's probably
right however if you go narrow I have a
friend right now who I said uh you
should do a podcast and you should do it
on these two interests that he got back
to me and he's like okay I'll do it on
this and it was so broad it was like
every other podcast I go no no these two
things are what you're into so if you're
into waffles and breakfast and cycling
it should be called eggs and wheels with
Johnny Thompson everyone needs to try to
make a podcast do 10 20 episodes you'll
learn a ton from it you'll get some
social media content out of it not
everybody needs a podcast but everyone
should try